[Music]
this war is now cousin fighting cousin
Somali Clans are arming to take on an
either linked terror group and Shaban
this is a conflict with an
unconventional front line it's actually
hot spots all over the country but here
in hiran is the heart of this war
against
militia have them surrounded not far
from here
how many of your men do you have
surrounding al-shabab right now
they've got ground support from the
Somali National Army
and the heavy artillery of African Union
forces
you've got four locations yep what are
they location foreign
they go again
skirts they wear to farm are the new
government's weapon of choice in the
fight against and Shabbat
iCal for this is
legendary Army veteran and governor of
Heron is here to boost morale
foreign
[Music]
are now hiding within the community
and switching up their tactics
lower chabeli is the most fertile part
of the country now ravaged by drought
and planted bombs our operations today
at uh it provides explosive devices or
bombs ideas weapon of choice
it's a painstaking process they're
literally checking this road inch by
inch for explosive devices and because
this is soft sand it's very easy for a
shabab to plant homemade bombs
on this road alone Ugandan forces find
five to six explosives every day
it's a critical artery thinking the
Capital Market issue to the rest of the
country
applying food and fuel
when you're helping somebody's recover
from the effects of War
and then
covered care must affected us like it
affected any part of the world but now
the drought has been bad
and people are dying of hunger the
hungry man is an angry man
when Ugandan troops first came here the
Somali Army was barely operational now
they're partners
earlier this year the African Union
Mission in Somalia was renamed Atlas
African transition mission
more than 18 000 troops from Djibouti
Uganda Burundi Kenya and Ethiopia are
expected to withdraw from Somalia by the
end of 2024. is there a sense of this is
a Somali problem that should be handled
by somalis no there we were coming as
the first lesson is African solidarity
African solution for African protein
problems that's said by latex Mandela
we move with burundian Atmos troops to
another hot spot balad it's only an hour
from Mogadishu and close to al-shabab's
former capital
and for their mayor this fight is
personal uh
The Mao Weasley are here too
resting before heading back out
and where do you get your equipment from
in your arms
Farmers now Fighters
a Grassroots offensive in a never-ending
War
Sky News Somalia